[Music]
fan Corrections this of course is a
segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show
I know laughable yes you are right to
laugh well so far hundreds of
challengers not one winner not one
because we don't make mistakes don't we
don't oh we don't all right that's
enough tonight
you're overdoing it tonight a fan named
Jorge Moreno thinks he caught a mistake
he says it happened when I was talking
recently to actress Mila Kunis about her
movie Jupiter ascending hey Conan iPhone
an era when you were interviewing Mila
Kunis for the movie to Paris and then
beautiful we're talking about the scene
which is on top of the Sears Tower and
you refer to it as our machine with you
atop the Sears Tower and then I found
out afterwards that was not a special no
we were on top of the Sears Tower the
Sears Tower was renamed to the Willis
Tower in 2009 you guys got to get up to
date
you all seem to think that the that
Jorge has me he's got me possibly yeah
well I'm sorry Jorge you are dead wrong
you see when I interviewed Mila Kunis in
February the Willis Tower was called the
Sears Tower don't believe me check out
this clip from the Willis group's
shareholders meeting held earlier this
year and that's just one of several
programs which should only lead to
further growth okay now I'd like to
announce something very exciting as all
of you know we own the naming rights to
the Willis Tower
Chicago's tallest building well
beginning in February we're going to
start naming the tower after the Willis
group Employee of the Month
how's that for incentive in February
we'll be honoring a payroll specialist
in our Philadelphia office trainee
Shishir the building will be known as
the Sears Tower
[Applause]
in March we'll honor a terrific benefits
consultant in our Seattle office
jerry eiffel i can't wait to visit the
Eiffel Tower in the spring
congratulations tray Nietzsche and yeah
so the challenge still stands if you
think you spotted an air op nah nah show
reported at team koco.com slash haha i
find that ever we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you've got
what it takes to make chump meat out of
the maestro
[Applause]
you